[Music]
hey guys so we're starting this new
segment called off-the-record where it's
pretty much like an open discussion we
give you guys updates on stories we
talked about in the past or updates on
our personal lives so yeah so this
winter break I went to Dallas and we
spent the Christmas vacation with
Casey's family are you okay speaking of
Casey's mom y'all hurt is the grab game
as the kids say is Dabba rippy nature
picture dopest [ __ ] how she know that do
men dude photos are [ __ ] dope man I
can't wait til she posts and she's a
trembler I had no [ __ ] idea she have
pictures of goats and [ __ ] on
mountainside yes and they survived which
is crazy that's pretty cool telling us
about how like they went up they did
like some tour type of thing where they
had like an entire camp and they went up
like the hill like to get to Machu
Picchu but I like the whole llamas and
everything and then yeah llamas not
goats my bad people Casey's mom just
killing the hike in case he's bad like
he wants to be Carrie no it's funny cuz
they had one horse available for the
people that were in that group you had
to share a horse well like one horse in
case like someone wants to take a break
from walking cuz it's like a three-day
walk though yeah like there was like
camping and stuff and then so it was
funny because it was mama and then this
other lady that was there part of the
group yeah I can see that was the only
one that was on the horses hogging the
[ __ ]
that's how it's supposed to be I picture
that he knows what's up my legs too
fragile for this man I thought your mama
they wanted like do more traveling like
this upcoming hearing stuff so they're
so young and fresh do yeah I'm so used
to like Asian parents that don't speak
English but they speak English like we
came here since early I know but he
always throws me off
David I'm a stuff but what I hear you
went to Sacramento right yeah you know
what though I will say this didn't feel
like winter this year that's right it
wasn't though the winter feeling wasn't
there last year that winter feeling was
poppin yeah I felt it in my spirits I
thought the snow globe form on my head
is [ __ ] it was it was long does this
know where you live in sacramento's if
it does is very rare ah it wasn't as
cold as it was last year and it's just
the festivities just more Nonpoint like
I wasn't like you know still waited
double-dutch the whole time like okay
okay Christmas and I couldn't jump in
yeah you know what's that weathers like
getting slower like later and later
yeah all the pears man that dyin that's
true what does that do it anything feels
like winter is gonna be like in summer
and then summers gonna be a winter like
it's Australia has like some crazy crazy
freezing weather this is ahead of falls
it's frozen over like the Falls that's
supposed to be moving it just yeah
there's just frozen the whole thing
frozen no no but this year this year
it's yeah all the way that's a crazy
[ __ ] just has to feel like you know what
it was to this because I didn't go to
Sacramento as early as I thought I was
going to Andover hero was so [ __ ] hot
yeah yeah it barely got called last week
this is this is what I [ __ ] hate so
I'm trying to get to the Christmas food
in LA right and I'll get outside my
place is really cold I'll walk out but
first of all don't fall no leaves change
no [ __ ] leave changing and these
spray paint the grass white do some [ __ ]
right you don't I mean and then I'm
trying to listen to Christmas music but
[ __ ] there's in Pasadena by the way
there's like 8,000 parents why the [ __ ]
are their parents in Pasadena a ton of
hair isn't happening what the [ __ ] is
that about so at first I was like and
I'm not to be just like what country am
i but apparently they're from Mexico oh
you're taking over [ __ ] so what's
happening with those parents but you're
on the parent family no part of the
Mexico family Oh weirdest thing to be
proud of by the way like parent
they're [ __ ] like we're part of the
problem alright it's the Mexican
invasion so they're actually going
extinct in Mexico but they're actually
thriving really well out here yeah
they're going extinct that was funny my
uncle actually had to smuggle a couple
parrots over here so he's probably the
reason why Jesse why not smuggling
parrots because they're the type of the
type of one that he got is illegal here
they're invasive maybe but you would
tell me like how he would get like the
keyline and make it drinking and the
[ __ ] parrot just passes out so it's
not like talking to the trunk and the
border dude those birds are [ __ ] loud
- they're not like American birds where
they just like eat my sandwich
nothing like that [ __ ] poker look
will be dude
so Mexican birds ruin Christmas - yes no
they don't you tropical I didn't like it
how do you feel about gifting for
Christmas
gifting adults gifting holy gift kids
Michael Jackson got my back again today
what do you mean by gifting like giving
gifts to adults what's wrong with that
people feel right I didn't say there's
anything wrong with it I just said what
are your thoughts on it I think it's
cool why pretty cool why you friends and
family members got or because a hundred
percent I picked it up so why do you
like I'm in charge of the guy gifts one
gave me a gift
did you give David a gift I'm still
working on it you see it doesn't matter
oh you know he was asking about the
headphones cause I'm about to get you
have some headphones like those how cute
you know what it is though a great gift
would be for him not to give me [ __ ] for
at least one week he can't do that
that's not saying it was not talking
[ __ ] who's got
least one we couldn't give you shake he
somehow somehow does it do a test
conversation I feel like you having a
great time this is gonna be a great day
you work out probably none over
Christmas I went to go visit my family
and I got about one two three I got
about five nephews and nieces there and
I got each of them like five gifts like
one oh I got I got one of my nieces a
backpack and within this like Totoro
backpack there was like stationery there
was erasers how did you know to pick
that cuz I'm a child
is he was exactly no no like I know she
would like it and in the so I think me
and Jes we didn't have we didn't get
much when we were kids so we were
shopping we're shop shopping for our
childhood self oh I wish we had like I
wish I had like ten gifts I only got
like yeah so I wrap it up right we go
over there and I'm like oh [ __ ] I forgot
adults my uncle's might watch my
cousin's and I got a box of mochi for
them that we could all share yeah tells
it adults don't need [ __ ] though because
they can get it for themselves that's
the thing kids need gifts because they
can't get [ __ ] they're [ __ ] broke
really appreciate it because in this
year for Christmas like all the kids
like like did a poll and like we just
gotta like whole bunch of gift cards for
them and like presents yeah well I give
it to my parents because my mom says I
have to so there's no good man let me
let me tell you what happened so I'm
talking to my mom on the phone right and
I go hey so what do you want for
Christmas she goes oh I don't need
anything and I said what if I give you
money that would be nice right and I'm
like all right cool well I'll just give
you like I don't know
I'll give like 20 50 bucks you go by
yeah that's what she goes she goes well
if you're gonna give me that just don't
give me anything at all and I'm like let
me tell you something [ __ ]
you have ruined Christmas look I was
like that's not so I'm going to this
there she goes well lasted blah blah
blah blah so we started yelling at each
other she's negotiating her rate she
goes it was too hot and then we started
like yelling at each other right
and I was it and I told her I was like
when somebody gives you a gift it
doesn't matter what it is you just take
it with a warm heart and then that's it
I technically don't have the gift for
strangers though kids is it different so
here's the thing so this is what happens
so I see her in person that they pick me
up in airport I was like what's up
Grinch right actually I don't know what
that is do you want this money or not
Merry Christmas where she goes I'll take
it so I give her the money right she
goes 215 and I'm like what what do you
mean she goes I got doing it 250 and
split it in half for me and your dad so
I was only gonna get 125 like no [ __ ] I
was gonna give you 250 and then unless
whole time she thought you're gonna give
her 125 she got mad yes so I gave it
like two so I'll give her a raise every
year you know I'm saying like confetti
cuz I'm trying to go to crazy you know
I'm saying so 250 and then I'll top of
that I find her dinner or whatever else
you need yeah so it's really not 250
bucks it's a lot more but she was giving
me [ __ ] about that is she ruined
Christmas I understand why though why
she looks at your face and she regrets
that she gave birth to you every [ __ ]
that's not true you Parisian hooker we
we the ice news day I was checking my
Twitter and it just blew up with all
Logan pool so did you guys hear it was
yeah pretty in the friends because
someone that I didn't even know was part
so I I'm part of the YouTube world right
but then I'm also kind of part of the
fitness world that I love local no I
can't Paul lover
big I thought he was cool in the
beginning like when he was fresh I'm
like have you honest before this whole
thing since I don't watch all his videos
but watch this beginning once I actually
like them exactly yeah that's a cool
positive young kid yeah and then until
the whole thing spilled and I started
going back and watch them the other
stuff and I'm like what the fuss was a
douchebag
yeah that's cuz we know two years ago
Logan Paul or three years ago Logan Paul
on vine or like when he would like pop
out of the audience and he's doing his
thing or whatever what did he used to do
it used to do that thing like he would
pop out of
you usually get positive content before
but keep well were you saying uh so yeah
so I'm part of that fitness space so I
was someone that I follow in the fitness
world was like yay 2018 I hope I have it
better than Logan Paul and I'm like what
this must be huge if someone that's not
on YouTube in the fitness world is
talking about Logan Paul so I looked it
up and then I saw that like he did the
dumbest whole bunch of celebrities a
local radio station k-rock was talking
about Logan Paul everyone stop you know
what sucks is because when one person on
YouTube [ __ ] up then all of a sudden
it's a youtuber so everybody's [ __ ]
up that's what it sucks and on top of
that this fool got way more subs and way
more publicity it actually positively
affected him yeah he gained a ton of
more subscribers buckin apology videos
is like 30 million or some insane amount
right now and he monetize his apology
video yeah originally did so but he
doesn't monetize later some [ __ ] like
that but yeah I think the weird thing
about that is like YouTube has canceled
most people's channels for something so
minor like Tim got his channel to leave
ones for like cursing and having ass on
it but this guy literally has somebody
killed himself on a video and then they
don't leave it on that it's stupid like
it shows favoritism it shows a little
video and what I wasn't so upset about
like the suicide when I was okay just
like a young dumb guy it is not really
like culturally sensitive but then when
I watch to fill up the Frankl video and
it's him going all of Japan like troll
in Japan and like kind of bullying the
older Japanese dude than even kind of
police officer I was like what dump that
mean want to kick his ass because like
the suicide more like some people just
aren't sensitive you know like a lot of
times I make jokes about like I don't
pedophilia whatever but you would never
go to a dead body and laughing it though
he like he was laughing at the bio
that's true that was and also to if
that's all at the green hat but he
didn't he wore the green hat before he
knew he was butch so he's like American
right and like as an American person
usually like a sign of respect it's like
they're taking us through this but I
will kept that [ __ ] on yeah he's white
and that's white culture yeah
he violated his own culture man what the
[ __ ] that's true
it just happens with the kid who just
doesn't he doesn't live in the real
world anymore and he doesn't get checked
and the problem with that is - it's like
he has a very young audience and these
kids actually think it's pretty [ __ ]
cool
so a my money savage yeah so in my mind
I'm like who are these [ __ ] kids like
I want to meet these kids so I can [ __ ]
these little kids up - we were all there
though I wasn't I was never like [ __ ]
stole I [ __ ] robbed I will never ever
make fun of somebody that died because
of suicides morals
oh I'll steal from a [ __ ] but I
will not make fun of that but at a
really young age your your Idol can know
about what do you mean by 12 or 8 ah
younger than that like what maybe
between life so I would say maybe from
like 8 - like maybe 13 okay and I think
I think within that that like you can't
relate to anyone
yep I never made fun of I never followed
any like suicide joke comedian guys I'm
not saying myspace and I would say I
like Superman so they don't follow him
because of that they follow that him
because he's this cool guy like cool
bigger older brother that that does
really immature [ __ ] that really is
aligned with the age that they're in and
they're like you know what a key best up
people myself but they don't understand
the severity of like what we're saying
is that we they do we they should
because we understood it you know what I
mean like death was something that we
just never made fun of like I'm not
saying that they don't I just think they
don't really understand the repercussion
of all it I work but we I understand
what you're saying but my point is is
that that's not okay I think what it is
is the as the god complex that the kids
basically they idolized him so much to
the point where an average person doing
something they would probably go yeah
that's [ __ ] up but because it's their
loved Logan Paul he can do no wrong
gotcha I think I think that's that's the
like they know everyone knows yeah
you're not no one you know no one can
sit here and go like yeah you know it's
it's not that bad recording someone that
just died and on camera it's not that
bad I think like also - cuz like YouTube
should have like a certain amount of
social responsibility with that hundred
percent yeah you know what it means so
if you know if that's the case just been
getting [ __ ] already for
allowing all these inappropriate videos
into like YouTube kids and sub where it
should be there and so this should be
one he should have his channel deleted
and he was started and he should start a
new channel three times exactly and
that's not fair like it's it's [ __ ]
dumb you know I feel like there's like
petition to try to get his you see how
many dear YouTube open letters are so I
just came across the whole Logan popping
so I'll just I typed in Logan upon
YouTube and there's a bunch of channels
they're like 5 million 4 million 10
million everyone's like dear YouTube
dear Logan Paul and all of those open
letters to him all have like millions
and millions of you see like everyone's
upset fellow content creators former
friends for celebrities yeah they're
disgusted with him I think because he he
didn't step up to the plate and man up
Jesse pinkman's mad at him yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah because he had a shitty
apology man that apology was like oh I
get my views don't worry about that like
it was just so like self-indulgent it
was not an apology
coupled with the fact that he was trying
to like convince himself and telling
people like it's for awareness no it was
so sad he try to be like some heat
instead of saying my bad I I got caught
up in wanting views yeah if he said that
like you know like I'm so [ __ ] like
at this point where what's the next
thing that's gonna get me more views
everyone knows how you two worked it's
like if you're relying on shock and
drama every time you got to go crazier
crazyer how do you top the last one for
him it was just another one it was like
let's just [ __ ] record some [ __ ] dead
body okay cold it's not you know it's
it's it's just this is gonna give you
this is gonna be crazy even amped it he
was just in the description and then
like when he was like hitting up his
fans he's like you guys are like this
has never been recorded before this has
never been before like hyped it up I
mean it's gonna get to the point where
it's like next level the president
sucking the donkey and I got [ __ ]
footage yeah or whatever you know it's
like it's gonna be crazy [ __ ] yeah I
think that what I find kind of like what
sucks and like how he's lying is the
whole suicide awareness thing where it's
like your audience is english-speaking
so how are you gonna do suicide
awareness in a country where it
suicide cultures it's completely
different it's like me going to like
some starving nations in Africa and
going I just want to show some hunger
awareness but it's like but none of my
audience is African speaking you know
what I mean it's like that news that I'm
documenting it doesn't apply to my
audience so to me like that just
[ __ ] seems extremely phony because
he didn't even try to understand the
culture of why people commit suicide in
a lot of Asian countries and he's not
being sensitive to anything they give
any resources either for like if he
really was trying to raise awareness
yeah it's like you didn't put anything
there's no nonprofit suicide awareness
hotline nothing it's just I just want to
show the world that their suicide that's
happening it would even make sense
because it'd be like hey if you're
feeling sad and you want to kill
yourself or whatever call this Japanese
number like you just would even like him
doing that whole bit in Japan for
suicide a nurse just doesn't make any
sense for his America especially the way
he was laughing at the person and it's
like oh my god it's not a person dead
that's all they were [ __ ] acting like
yeah scuse for like laughing at it he's
like that's how I cope he was dying you
know how I cope I cope by [ __ ] people
up yeah I think he needs a spanking I
one of my fantasies is to pull his
[ __ ] path down and spank him like a
baby that just shows you his family
because his brothers a [ __ ] annoying
little kid too and on the recently is
his brother was supposed to be the worst
one relations like Disney or something I
don't know man I mean that's what I'm
saying like I'm not saying I have a
foresight into human moves but I saw his
channel and I was like this guy's a
little piece of [ __ ] I said it's day one
I said what about his little [ __ ]
brother too and everybody's like oh so
positive Claude there's something off
about a person like that they just don't
live in the real world and it always
happens it bleeds out like you could I
think as a person just because like
we're older and then we've interacted
with human beings that we had that
social experience I think when we see
somebody we could be like something off
about this [ __ ]
don't know what it is but it bleeds out
of it I like when you sit in a video and
it was his actions aren't a mistake it's
a rough select reflection of him as a
human being I like that a lot
it is it is and everybody keeps all
people make mistakes but there's
difference between mistakes yeah and
then who that person is and when you
watch that video it's who he is is how
he was raised which by the way parents
good job by the way good [ __ ] job too
good
yeah your kids are [ __ ] fantastic
you're [ __ ] garbage you're worse than
your [ __ ] kids because you raised
them so [ __ ] you a mistake is when you
accidentally hurt your friend
unintentionally yeah it's the intention
behind it yeah cuz I can intent his
intention you can clearly he got caught
it's not a mistake he got caught
yeah man that's not a mistake you got
[ __ ] for your [ __ ] fraudulent
behavior yeah you sack of [ __ ] lying
sack of [ __ ]
[Music]